Film Courage: How does someone know what story
to write?
Evan Kidd, Filmmaker/Podcaster: I think a
lot of times before you write a story you
have to ask yourself why do I need to be the
person to tell it?
And a lot of times you have to say is there
anyone else better qualified than me?
I think sometimes people think I can tell
every story, I can tell any story.
Maybe?
But for me it’s always what am I qualified
to tell?
I prefer to tell stories that have some semblance
of truth in my life or someone I know or something
I’ve seen just because to me they feel a
little more personal.
I would certainly take a check from HBO to
write for GAME OF THRONES but I can’t quite
relate to the fantasy character and dragons
and whatnot in the same way that I can relate
to more real and naturalistic things that
happen in my life.
And that’s not to say that you can’t incorporate
those things in a fantasy piece or surreal
piece or anything like that.
But just for me I tend to gravitate toward
the kind of more naturalistic real to life
things whether it’s funny stuff, serious
stuff, more experiential based things I’ve
gone through.
Film Courage: What advice do you have for
someone who can’t finish writing their story?
Is that possibly the wrong story for them?
Or it just hasn’t worked itself out yet?
Evan: I think when you write something you’re
always going to hit a roadblock somewhere.
I’d be kind of surprised if you made it
through smooth sailing without hitting any
kind of roadblock.
If you’re struggling though I would say
think about why.
Is it because you’re not connecting if you’re
not caring about the characters it could be
that because if you don’t care about your
characters the audience definitely won’t
care about your characters and so I’ve noticed
over the years with writing like I mentioned
earlier there is a couple of scripts on my
computer that sit unfinished and a lot of
that is because I couldn’t figure it out.
A lot of times it was I lost interest you
know?
It stopped being fun to write.
For me whenever writing isn’t enjoyable
anymore I put it on ice, I pause it and I
say I can’t do this right now.
Maybe a year from now I pick it back up and
it’s more interesting.
Maybe I have lived enough life in that year
of time where I am able to see the characters
with new eyes.
But a lot of times it could be that the characters
are too much for the writer.
It could be that the writer doesn’t have
the experience or the writer doesn’t need
to be the person telling that story.
Maybe there’s a more qualified writer to
tell it.
I think it could certainly vary.
Film Courage: What about caring about your
character too much?
Evan: Yes, caring about your character too
much I think is essential though.
I think if you don’t care too much then
maybe you don’t care at all?
I don’t know.
I think I’ve never quite felt…and this
is only me speaking…lukewarm or neutral
to any of my characters.
When I write the main character itself I think
I want to go to bat for these characters.
I really want to fight for them.
I want them to win even if it’s a sad story.
I want them to find some kind of catharsis
whether they find it in the film or not.
A lot of times I’ll leave a film vague and
I’ll say maybe they do, maybe they don’t.
But I like to at least crack the door a little
bit.
So yes, I think caring about your characters
is super crucial.
I would say the only reason to be cautious
of caring too much would be if you feel that
you’re showing a bias toward that character
at the expense of all your other characters.
For instance, if you care so much about your
main character that none of the other characters
in your film get to challenge that main character,
get to grow with that main character.
I like to think that main character starts
the film and ends the film a different person
unless there is something you’re going for
that they don’t do that.
But in most films you want to see some sort
of journey for your character.
Question For The Viewers: What are the biggest
reasons why you have stopped writing a screenplay?